hello and welcome to this video playing
black coffee Grandmaster black coffee
let's see if I can get my kept line and
I guess again see for I feel I had this
against him already but I have no clear
recollection how it worked
Taiyo it's how it ended and so on but
we'll see yeah here you can play still
play h5 or play this I think this is
also quite ok for Knight f5 and some
pressure against deform leads to an
interesting position as well it looks a
bit strange at the moment but once the
night comes to f5 it all makes some
sense the default point is under some
pressure and it seems we should reform
he felt was an issue but ok now
immediately I feel this is really nice
look like once white pushes d5 those two
knights are extremely annoying Plus this
Bishop all of a sudden becomes fantastic
please me I'm not saying it's terrible
for white is but I think like this
position is really quite ok
yeah it's tough to not play this in the
long run but f4 is to the weakening move
if you want to really push the night
away
hmm I don't
I don't have a clear plan forward though
it looks nice but what am I doing with
it I would definitely like to connect
rooks but I didn't quite see how Queen
yeah the Queen doesn't have a good
square I am Queen f6 kind of voice gets
into gets attacked okay this is kind of
a non move but I didn't really see
anything fantastic maybe just like rook
the eighth and I could create Bishop c8
so that at least I've got the rooks
connected
michael knight c6 Knight h5 that's
that's annoying that those Knights are
somewhat annoying
Nachi six-night h5 i don't have a good
move then night h5 is bit of a threat
I don't quite see a good setup hmm if
you played that well it seems I don't
really see anything great here I mean I
didn't expect to be clearly better or so
with them somehow it seems white is very
okay and I didn't think I should have
any problems they're so not so easy I
cannot easily play their poor nurse to
the big horn on e3
is that really good like f5 or something
I don't believe it
95 Queen g6 it's somehow how to how to
believe that he can do this G form I
mean my pieces are not well planned not
badly placed I thought it takes it I can
take with the Queen here like late on
age three or almost made on age three
and ninety three so he cannot take it
and if you cannot take what is this move
it must be 95 but then Queen G 6 to 6
this is annoying and for my yes to play
but if I can I can just take amongst
others probably F for 94 doesn't look I
think it might work but I can take I can
just take on G form with the pawn both
Knights are hanging then and let's let
cannot end well
I think it's almost close to media and
there's still the a7 bishop an extremely
strong piece okay if I take this g3 is
almost made just have to cover it yes
somehow hey I can take it up threatening
g3 mate y can check then everything
comes with the check and the trade
Queens and there's something more
convincing you this is very convincing
you do it can't have a maid I would
really like to end it with made just EDM
[Music]
he wants to take em I'm slowly cramped
here
and I should have maybe tried tried for
a different solution here this is some
this is not bad and I would probably win
on time but still here I cannot move my
pieces even though I am a piece up
okay I'm returning and returning this
I had rook on the seventh floor
okay I'm two paws up so winning on time
is kind of okay I thought it over there
I shouldn't I probably should have
thought I should try to find something
that is easy em yeah I felt like here
after this I should be very okay but he
didn't he did a good job
off of playing this I think Queen f6
maybe there is something I mean I've
thought about something like this of
course this is not possible so but I
felt like after practice he might still
be able to play Knight e4 later and then
I don't know where to go with the Queen
as 96 s 9f for Jeremy I don't think you
don't think I wasn't in big trouble to
make many hours he engine doesn't like
my position all that much but this is
probably not good yeah I don't I don't
know it's probably not prepared well
enough
oh that's interesting
so f4 was strong testing so I should
have gone to h6 which prevents them of
course
oh no I didn't see FY is that dangerous
but we are looking at it there where
where do you go with no it is a lot
better in comparison of course changing
f5 isn't in third grade iam f4 is still
okay Wow
then think of that move you play this
which losers if I go here and then you
have an invitation to media check can I
enter these positions would be hell
against the conga because you will play
would be probably completely irritated
share the computer course not
yam here yeah some 90s is killing him
okay so this is this now probably I
always come to the age file and then
it's over
this is also it's pretty good yet so the
dismal in that grade iam it's better to
play can't play this yeah can take be
tuned up and also here
oh no that isn't even good because of
your f7o and yeah this now I mean Kelly
this is something that that a computer
would definitely win easily with black
but it's still not it's still a little
bit little bit cramped engines decided
to make it to avoid getting majors yeah
because I knew I would win all time okay
guys thanks for watching